sono tutti ragazzi e benvenuti questo
nuovo ascella io sono fare i geni oggi e
siamo tornati su questo gioco che
continua a essere sempre più
inspiegabile tratto solo adesso ho
notato che bella forchetta cia sta tizia
sicuramente non ci mangi neanche le
pappe dei bambini costa forchetta che
poi lei obesa quindi come caso è
possibile
lasciamo perdere tanto sto gioco già è
tutto strano non focalizziamoci sulle
posate cento per cento impossible poco
sembra easy per adesso l'altro vedo una
mina qua quindi magari prendo prima mina
un gioco di merda ragazzi un gioco di
merda perché devo essere sempre io a
fare questi di perché 1000 cm perché poi
me li scelgo pure ecco guarda mi sto di
composto vale
complimenti zio però di restare altra
parte devi arrivare 1 e 2 mica quanti
addominali frate 1234 mic è un fenomeno
come sono pronti gli arpioni uccidermi
ogni mio passo mi seguono mi chiama con
una lezione di yoga
[Musica]
io credo che veramente un piccione morto
abbia più forza nelle braccia di steam e
i piccioni non hanno le braccia ragazzi
come faccia vincere o arrivare sulla
mina ok ci sei sono dimenticato che il
traguardo stava un chilometro più a
sinistra però sa bene quanto può essere
difficile a livello di è più ist
forse troppo adesso adesso io rimango
quasi in questo livello non lo faccio
perché impossibile o due gambe gomme
pistorius non dai ragazzi ma non è
possibile accedere mente non spara ma
cosa cazzo è il suo livello non ho mai
giocato a un arthur come
e stavo proprio per dire la stessa cosa
stava proprio per dire che questo è un
livello del cazzo e che è fattibilissimo
non avete mica frainteso le mie parole
stj ma in run perché se tj avevano
scrivere il mio nome mi hanno sbagliato
i fior don plain dominos guest star che
stavo leggendo scusatemi quindi io devo
stare attento che quando butto giù le
cose ci sono le mine va bene che culo
cosa ho schivato veloce veloce race ok
moro space ed out perfetto cam ignota
bye bye bye bye bye bye bye veloce zio
veloce zio che con o ragazzo rendono
incredibile non avete idea super player
master god
questo è impossibile non è così non è
possibile ma veramente come ho fatto a
morire alla fine come ho fatta vorrei
alla fine doppia v con queste porno rock
swing folk level coop tanto quelle il
copy contento che io faccio i suoi
livelli vero uno yes it's possible for
che è ma quanto sei storto ce la posso
fare ragazzi se lo fa quella il copro
faccio anch'io quella il corpo non si
sarebbe fatto così male però sono ancora
vivo ci sta incubando un ago cosa stai
facendo
aridaje mica è un macello per farsi
livelli ma scusate ragazzi sta ordinando
il cibo è che devo prendere il sushi
mima un morellino di scansano docg e
alla pesca tè al limone coca cola
prendiamo anche dell'acqua esiste nella
con naturale che bello 2 oggi sboccio va
bè ragazzi venata 2.3 l'inps è in vena
io sono fa vj potts gravi di sto cazzo e
beata e beata beata fa vj corazzata
potionkin
ho anche vinto se urlo la parola
corazzata portiamo che ogni volta che
salto vinco proviamoci 1 per cento
bossico provo è poi magari non è così
corazzata potemkin ha funzionato cos'è
che posizione 6 fratello caccia trojan e
ho da sempre peggio rega incredibile
va bene ce l'ho fatta non so neanche
cosa purtroppo o facevano suor troppi
che nei sei anni che ne faccio uno con
no ma cosa fai il nonno sei scemo e
scemo jane di cialde facciamo è di ore
che veramente non acciacco ultimamente
saranno di testa perfetto
devo prendere solo così in alto che
vestito veramente di merda perché non
riesca a prenderlo grazie che mi ha
ridato la spara sono un deficiente ho un
cuore sul naso e in pochi possono fare
questo gioco di prestigio
siccome ragazzi se rimango qua fermo
cade da solo scommettete la manovra non
sapevo lo sapevo lo sapevo ci avrei
scommesso hard a tutto questo con un
cuore in bilico sul naso electric bike
gp cazzoli represse space to turn on the
bike giorno device perché una tipa obesa
mi sta ingrossando dato a vicino puoi
trovare la mia brutta [__]
togliti e [__] bastard ma che cosa me
ne cosa stai facendo ok perfetto piano
lo seminata ho seminato la [__]
ma non è così male come roma che così mi
recuperarlo mi sento una tartaruga
sapete tipo gli animali che non vogliono
farsi inglobare vengono puntualmente
inglobati dalla loro stessa specie ecco
la stessa cosa ma cosa stai facendo
va beh almeno di un utile vidar cazzo no
bubi non sto cliccando niente sta
andando da sola mi sto solo raddrizzando
perché non riesce a farlo da solo però
funziona e la bici elettrica su
hoepli.it ragazzi 2016
l'anno della rivoluzione
bc 6 se non va adesso devo premere io
sono non va quanta poca autonomia cia
cosa stai facendo nonno non si possono
fare queste cose cos'è un orgia 99 per
cento che tutti impossible oggi che
problema c'è make your choice
io lo faccio meglio fermi un attimo
[Musica]
allora se non ti muovi li entro 5
secondi ti ammazzo la famiglia la
famiglia anzi tra la tortura la famiglia
[Musica]
iolo
non riesco a parlare questa cosa che
brutta sensazione non fatemi domande non
chiedetemi perché ho una maschera di
jigsaw in casa zitto zitto football
shooter o questo mi sembra figo click
qua powerslide mica sono un fenomeno
come zanzare start laver ora fermi che
lo faccio meglio da ragazzi che cos'è il
chip gol al pallone il cucchiaio il
cucchiaio bene come pirlo 50 per cento
imposti volevo dire che la metà delle
persone che lo fa ci riesce solo la metà
e io sono nella meta sbagliata che
pareva ovviamente che attrae assicuro
che il 50 per cento e nel 99 porca eva
non sostare in altissimo secondo me
questa data pd capo si sparano perfetto
fantastico quando dici le cose giuste e
succede esattamente quello che che tu
avevi detto tipo quando fai le verifiche
di matematica però li puntualmente
invece non azzecchi un cazzo you news su
al challenge cosa vuol dire ai player
scoprì di sly viaggio in ciad barry va
bene se me lo dice un pupazzo di neve
certo che sì kung fu master miss ginnas
c'è anche misto a mamma da qualche parte
comunque miss ginnasta circola la fabula
miss non la vedo è bagnata la ministra
stategia sposami con la mina lo devo
scavalcare sto tizio perché no perfette
volato non dichiaratevi uomini finite
così non aveva la capitana quanto
fastidioso questo livello
benissimo perfetto
porcaccia eva niente regali e assurdo
ok michiara difficile mi si è staccata
pure una gamba
come fai a essere così [__] quali
problemi al cervello frate quali pro
quanti soprattutto minchia rega che
nervoso perché non riesco a fare un
livello che da mongo poetici perché non
ce la faccio devi morire male perfetto
non ci sono più mine non c'è un buco
c'era un buco sull'europa perfetto
sono ancora vivo e in tutto questo porca
eva perfetto ce l'ho fatta sono salvo
non so come mai non sarà un salvo nel
senso sono salvatore sono surreal power
dai vai vai vai bye bye bye bye bye
perfetto che mi sono cagato addosso in
maniera che non avete idea lo toccarli
sti cosi non devo toccarli pro vinto ho
visto va bene ragazzi basta ho deciso
che basta però che vi dove sia piaciuto
spero che siate più calmi di me in
questo momento che spaccherei qualcosa
ma va bene devi stare zitto o madonna
che devo fare sti lavori forca eva
arrivo adesso è che i ragazzi stranieri
sia piaciuto caso isolato è un casino
parlare questa cosa perché la bocca ti
arriva esattamente qui e non riesci
proprio a neanche poco a dire [__]
ecco perché nel film non parla mai sto
tizio perché mi sembra impossibile cosa
che mi è piaciuta sull'argomento è un mi
piace ha già facendo i facebook cavani
l'iscrizione sono serviti schiavano
prossimo vito era ragazzi
[Musica]